what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with Invincible Iron Man which
you guys absolutely loved so this takes
place both before the attack on krakowa
and then after the attack on gracoa just
kind of something to keep in mind but
the thing about this is that with Tony
Stark's entire business basically being
taken over by the Rabid anti-mutant guy
Fey long which of course a lot of you
guys have made reference to the guy from
Street Fighter which is a fair synopsis
to come up with write a fair uh belief
to come up with that Tony Stark no
longer has control of his own company
and even his own Stark Tech the Iron Man
suits those all belong to Stark
Industries because remember one of the
things that Tony Stark had done over the
years is that in building the Iron Man
suits they were all business ventures
right they were all like tax deductible
things which means they're products of
the company itself and so legally he has
to hand them over now what is going on
is that around this time Captain krakowa
whose identity we still don't know the
what is effectively associated with the
mutant population had launched an attack
on Washington DC so the Avengers
themselves responded if you guys recall
the video that we did at the very
beginning of fall of X when the attack
was launched and like Rogue and Captain
America and those guys just took off
from the Hellfire gala this is what they
were responding to but by the time Tony
Stark gets there the fight's more or
less done right things are effectively
over so you do have Rogue and you do
have Captain America they're kind of
tending to their own business and then
Stark starts to realize that the
Sentinels are on the prowl again now
this takes place right when the attack
on Cocoa happens right so they're sort
of happening simultaneously and so
that's why when Stark gets here and he
realizes that the Sentinel has Tracked
Down Emma Frost from the X-Men alongside
Wilson Fisk Kingpin that it goes to
attack them both now a little bit of an
aside here because it's not overly
important but it does provide context
Kingpin technically has residency on the
mutant nation of krakowa no he's not a
mutant but he is married to Typhoid Mary
and Typhoid Mary Mary Walker herself is
a mutant so it's by extension of that
marriage that he can be granted
citizenship now the reality is the quiet
council could have just notified that
they could have said we don't care that
you're married you do not get to be part
of the inner Council or even part of
pakoa itself but the reality here is
that Wilson
he's a villain is
our whole I to have on your side not
even just because of what he's capable
of on a personal level but because of
all the contacts that he has but because
of all the contacts he has in the
criminal underworld in the government
and so on and so forth so he's the guy
you want on your side up until that
point he was the black king of the
hellfire club we'll talk more about that
here in a little while but Emma Frost
immediately goes on the response here
right like literally Iron Man tells her
I warned you guys in the last Hellfire
Gala things were only going to get worse
and none of you believe me and that's an
accurate statement right not the current
Hellfire gala where everything popped
off but the one from last year right
that's one of the things we talked about
in that story ever since Jonathan
Hickman took over the X-Men every year
Marvel releases a comic called the
Hellfire Gala and either it's a
reshuffling of the X-Men roster or some
kind of new team is created but whatever
it is you end up seeing a kind of shift
in the status quo during the previous
Hellfire Gala Iron Man warned Emma Frost
and the rest of the mutants on cricola
really the quiet Council that them
acting in this way which is to say
creating their own mutination and so on
and so forth it would make people
fearful right Humanity would respond in
the most predictable way now a lot of
people you could argue could have seen
this coming but one of the things you
remember about Tony Stark he's a
futurist he's always looking to the
Horizon he's always looking at what's
coming down the road that combined with
his intelligence basically put him in a
position where he's like I'm surprised
nobody else sees this I'm surprised
nobody else really believes this it's
only a matter of time before Humanity
launches a strike against the mutant
population and whether by their hubris
or whatever the case is they effectively
ignored him right they just kind of blew
him off and now it's all coming home to
ruse now his words are coming true now
what's cool is the Sentinels momentarily
just kind of send Tony Stark flying
right they momentarily overpower him and
the response of Emma as she's talking
directly to feilong who she assumes can
see her through the Sentinels themselves
and she she says like you're going to
regret attacking the entirety of the
X-Men and the full mutant population and
the response of FEI Long is like well I
mean I don't really feel regretful not
even a little bit right like it's just
you know it's just how things were going
to go but understand Emma Frost as she's
been depicted in more recent years in
Marvel Comics is just like the ultra
super attractive high-class ritzy girl
who doesn't like getting her hands dirty
no no no no that's just way Marvel's
done her character recently you go back
and you look at Emma Frost in like the
80s and the 90s now son she has no
qualms in getting her hands dirty and
when it comes down to it Emma Frost is a
chick you want on your side one because
she's an Omega Level telepath right
she's one of the most powerful telepaths
in existence in the Marvel Universe and
two once she goes into her Diamond form
she's basically indestructible and
that's exactly what happens granted she
can't like fly or anything like that but
she can certainly take these Sentinels
apart piece by piece by knocking out
their feet and then knocking out their
knees and as they collapse taking them
out right it's like Wolverine attacking
one of these things the funny thing is
Stark has his own plan and what he tells
her is you being here is just going to
be you getting in the way I'm not saying
that because I don't really need your
help or you're going to be useless or
anything it's just I've got a plan and
you're going to ultimately be a
distraction so in effect Emma Frost
basically leaves and then states that
she's gonna go on the hunt to try to
find any X-Men who are surviving so
those of you guys who are wondering what
was going on with Emma Frost at the time
in the immediate aftermath of fall of X
this is it because I know a lot of you
guys are asking that question so I
figured we'd answer it here now the
funny thing is where she would have just
gone about and done her own thing Tony
Stark is attacked by two of these
Sentinels and they're both enough to
overpower so almost immediately when he
said I have a plan the plan goes awry
and Emma Frost responds using her
telepathy because there's no indication
that he's alive here now you could kind
of say that Emma Frost would dismiss it
right and just say oh you know he'll be
fine but remember with the mutant
population under attack by Humanity
allies are few and far between and Tony
Stark is a friend of the X-Men right if
for no other reason than the fact that
they share a common enemy in the form of
FEI Long but Iron Man himself even
during the events of like Avengers vs
X-Men and that kind of stuff from back
in the day that he didn't necessarily
see the X-Men as straight up bad guys
and helping them where he could when he
could that was the effective thing that
he was trying to do so once Emma Frost
realizes he could die here they would
lose one of their most powerful allies
so entering into the mind of Tony Stark
she literally takes over his body and
then she starts controlling the Iron Man
suit which is dope now this is not new
right this is how Marvel explained to us
that back in the day Iceman is an Omega
Level mutant when Emma Frost took over
his body and then basically realized
just how powerful he could actually be
this is how he learned that Jubilee
could be in Omega Level mutant that her
little plasmoid things look like
fireworks are actually her detonate
dating matter and it's only a matter of
time before she can detonate matter on
the atomic or subatomic scale basically
create nuclear explosions where their
power possibly even blow up a whole
planet so again like it's one of these
instances where Emma taking over the
body of somebody is part and parcel to
her character we don't learn anything
new about Tony Stark here right it's not
like actually Tony Stark you're a mutant
and your power is to just be really
smart like Forge right I know they're
doing that with Miss Marvel and the Hand
wavy stuff that comes along with it but
what ends up happening is that even in
this moment where she's able to offer
some kind of Aid it's only just enough
to allow Tony Stark to kind of come too
and then in turn this Sentinels capture
her and they're going to kill her on the
spot right they're about to annihilate
her but the response of Stark is stop I
Surrender because at the end of the day
FEI Long is really going after Tony
Stark and a lot of it's just Pride but
that's really all it is and Tony Stark
realizes that he knows that it's the
pride of FEI Long that he's really
preying on here right if I can get Tony
Stark and I can get the last Iron Man
suit well then I can just go and grab
Emma Frost at some future point in time
right and so what this does is it grants
kind of a momentary reprieve in this
fight where basically Emma Frost's life
is saved she intends to stay fighting
she won't leave and so the response of
Iron Man is to basically have the suit
in case Emma Frost and then take off
literally taking her away from the
battlefield but because FEI Long
realizes now she's out of the picture
his attention immediately shifts away
from Iron Man himself and to Emma Frost
because Tony Stark introduces an idea
that FEI Long hadn't thought of right
I'm Tony Stark here in my normal human
form in the middle of the street if you
kill an Avenger out here for the world
to see you would be dead by Dawn because
sure Humanity doesn't like the mutant
population but Humanity loves The
Avengers it would be political suicide
to do something like this so FEI Long
ultimately kind of has to let him go and
in fact this is further complicated when
Captain America arrives on the scene
because a FEI Long to kill Captain
America and the eyes
public
there that orcas and FEI Long half is
gone right it disappears that's it
because the public loves Captain America
they cherish Captain America he's not a
guy you just take out and the public
just kind of shrugs it off and says well
you know I mean collateral damage but
that's just kind of the way he goes no
no no and so when Tony Stark makes his
way down into what are effectively the
Morlock tunnels I'll explain those here
in a second it's essentially revealed to
us that the Iron Man suit had flown all
the way down this far underground in
order to keep Emma Frost safe now the
Morlock Tunnels for those of you guys
who don't know and if you do know just
bear with me here for a second but the
Warlock tunnels were part and parcel to
the morlocks themselves historically in
Marvel Comics mutants have all kinds of
different powers and appearances but
most of them look like Emma Frost they
just look like regular people and you
would never know the difference between
a mutant and a regular human being but
the morlocks were mutants that had
powers or physical appearances or both
that were so extreme they couldn't
function on the surface world because of
their appearance they would immediately
be targeted by Humanity and so not
really being welcomed into the
traditional Xavier Institute or at least
not believing in the X-Men's cause they
took up residence underground now once
krakowa became a thing and the doors
were open to all mutants across the
world yeah the morlocks abandoned the
tunnels they took off to the island and
now they're one of the 250 000 mutants
that's been shuffled off to some
in-between Place between dimensions and
exodus is leading them into what's
basically going to probably be their own
demise or their own saving we don't
really know but the thing about this is
that as Iron Man and Emma Frost have
this discussion something to know she
doesn't know that the attack on Cocoa
has happened she's totally unaware of
that her attention has been focused on
the Sentinels and Iron Man this whole
time and so Tony Stark shows her his
phone it's all cracked and broken and
everything but it's literally the
headline from The Daily Bugle the mutant
Massacre no human survivors not only
that where orcas had published this
whole piece Through The Daily Bugle in
saying that the medicines that gracoa
was providing to humanity to wipe out
any kind of mental illness or to expand
their lifespan or cure any disease that
they were actually laced and that it was
kind of a backdoor way for the mutant
population to kill Humanity it was one
part true but it was one part false
orcas laced those medicines they
basically put the X-Men in a situation
to where they would look like villains
or at least the mutant population they
would look like bad guys and so Emma
Frost is now in this position where as
far as she's concerned she's the only
surviving mutant that's out there and
even when she uses her telepathy to scan
for the Stepford cacus right in essence
the teenage clones of her she can't find
them she refers to them as like her
daughters but they're really more clones
than anything else but it's a really
crushing moment here now a legitimate
question has to be asked in the moment
when orcas forced Charles Xavier to use
his telepathy to make every mutant on
Earth leave Earth and then travel
through the cacaoan gates to wherever
their destination took them but some of
those mutants were able to override the
influence of that power using a kind of
backdoor protocol that Xavier had
installed in their minds to override a
command like that if something like this
were to happen did it affect Emma Frost
and the answer seems to be no but we're
not really given an explanation why we
don't know if it's because she was
encased in the Iron Man suit and she was
this far underground or the command was
simply just not sent to her we're not
entirely sure I would go so far as to
argue it's the first one of the
protocols that Tony Stark built into the
Iron Man suit is to Shield it from
telepathic influence much in the same
way that Magneto's helmet protects him
from telepathic attack so that seems to
make the most sense and so what star
does is he says the entire mutant
population is being hunted some mutants
basically managed to survive on Earth by
whatever Manner and whatever means we're
not entirely sure again the other part
of that whole thing with the X-Men is it
did seem to be limited to krakowa itself
but there were other mutants in other
parts of the world that passed through
the gates so again it's a little kind of
in consistent in terms of how it was
handled by Marvel but he literally tells
her they're hunting for you and they
will find you these Sentinels cannot be
reasoned with you can't bargain with
them as soon as they locate you they
will try to kill you and I promise you
this Stark Tech is evolving and growing
under the control of FEI Long and orcus
to where it will overcome your diamond
form and it will kill you right so stay
here underground I will come back and I
will give you what you need information
something along those lines and so in
order to really kind of get FEI Long off
his Trail and with FEI Long unaware of
the fact that Stark and Emma are still
working together one of the things to
remember is that when the whole instance
of fei-long taking over Stark Industries
happened that Tony Stark had reached out
to Jennifer Walters right to She-Hulk
who's an attorney and one of the few
instances of Marvel when she actually
serves a purpose she had operated as the
lawyer of Tony Stark and in this
instance where he's talking to her she
tells him your best bet here is to
basically just hand the armor over right
hand the suit it over to FEI Long and
just walk away it's what he wants and
even if you have some kind of scheme
operating behind the scenes at the very
least it'll buy you time the other part
of this is that in an effort to get to
Tony Stark they long targeted the people
close to him specifically he went after
James Rhodes because what he knows is
that Stark will go to the ends of the
Earth to protect his friend and so In
This Moment Stark realizes handing over
the suit really is the best alternative
and he doesn't in the most interesting
way ever where he literally just throws
it through the front of the building
where it shatters the glass window now
one of the things about this and I think
it's one of the great ideas that they
did with this character he passes by a
liquor store and he's almost inclined to
indulge in alcohol because for those of
you guys who aren't really familiar with
the inner workings of Tony Stark there
was a story called demon in a bottle
where it was literally just focusing on
his battle with alcoholism it was a
phenomenal story it was really cool the
way that it was done but it's something
that he's always struggled with as a
character he's always struggled with
alcohol addiction and so on and so it's
one of these instances where it'd be
very easy for him to relapse instead
what he does is he basically goes and
just kind of gets little bits and Bobs
here and there that allows him to create
a kind of Disguise and then brings it to
Emma Frost and so this is how it is that
Emma Frost ends up getting that disguise
that we saw in like uncanny Avengers and
so on where she's walking around looking
like somebody else the other part of
this is Stark's still reeling from his
fight with the Sentinels and I wouldn't
go so far as to say that he's dying but
I will go so far as to say that his
body's struggling and so what happens is
Emma Frost enters into his mind in order
to allow him the opportunity to
communicate intelligently and adequately
without like struggling with the
physical ailments that are plaguing him
and what they do is they actually strike
a deal and it's one of the best things
that they could have done they build off
of what Typhoid Mary and Kingpin had
done that with Tony Stark being somebody
that's worked alongside the X-Men for so
long they decide to get get married and
the reason for this is that what it does
is with Emma Frost assets all of her
money basically being frozen by the
federal government due to the fact that
she's a mutant if the two of them get
married there's no warrant per se out
for Tony Stark there is one for Emma
Frost and while he is willing to at
least as he describes it earn the
Interpol warrant for right now that's
not out there so them being married
provides all of the benefits of a
married couple in essence because he
needs to build more Iron Man suits but
he has no Capital to do so remember in
the time that Emma Frost has been alive
due to her telepathy and any number of
things she's amassed a fortune it would
allow her to take her money and transfer
it to Tony Stark's accounts and in turn
he can operate and build whatever Iron
Man suits he needs with impunity and so
he gives her a wedding band
they're essentially engaged again
there's no real love here but it's one
of the smartest moves they could have
done use the legal system in their favor
so again it's what happens when you take
two people who are pretty intelligent
and allow them to work together more so
than that what she ends up doing is
saying we need to go to a place where we
can find Safe Haven where we can find
like-minded people that we can work
alongside that will help us achieve
their goals or at least our goals and in
turn will also help with their resources
and they go to the hellfire club now the
hellfire club for those of you guys who
don't know it's one of the coolest
things in Marvel Comics it's a coming
together of some of the wealthiest and
most influential people in the world not
everybody but those who traditionally
have their sights set on influencing the
world as opposed to conquering it right
so to use a really good example here
they don't want to be the people who are
finding gold in the great gold rush back
in the day they want to be the ones who
are selling the pickaxes and the shovels
because those are the people who were
making the money maybe a prospector
finds gold but you're guaranteed to get
rich selling the two tools that they use
to try to find gold so again it's a
really smart maneuver in terms of how
the hellfire club Works more so than
that what she does is she introduces him
to the white king of the hellfire club
basically the second most powerful
person there the White Queen would be
the most powerful but they're basically
two of the most capable people and we
end up finding out the person that's
going to help them do everything they
need to do in order to take out orcas
and try to help influence the return of
rights to the mutant population on Earth
is Wilson Fisk Kingpin I told you he was
important with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this to an end if you
need to get caught up on fall of X make
sure you click this link to the playlist
and I will catch you all later
peace